hello and welcome to Playstation
grenades a few months ago it looked like
Friday the 13th had been abandoned by
the developers and we all died a little
bit on the inside well not only were
those reports completely wrong but an
entire year of content has been mapped
out for us in Friday the 13th three more
pieces of DLC will be unleashed on us
with patch projects in a new counselor
named Mitch a new weapon type a new map
and a round of emotes to get our teeth
into or rather our pig splitter into for
a nine-second the latest Jason been
added to the mix is from Friday the 13th
the final chapter aka and lovingly
referred to as part for Jason last time
we spoke about this game I put my money
on Pat 5 Jason joining the crew but I'm
happy to be wrong Pat for Jason comes
with what I'm reliably told is a pig
splitter which looks to be like a
slaughterhouse version of a good old
butcher's cleaver only 100 times more
dangerous and a thousand times more
frightening in the hands of Jason parts
for Jason is completely free but comes
with a level 44 caveat
so get grinding if you aren't there
already we all know a new Jason is all
about brutal kills so here is one you
savages enjoy
[Music]
other kills included WWE style
piledriver and a good old decapitation
we are now completely desensitized to
[Music]
with the new Jason from part four it's
only right to have a new location from
the same movie and here it is the Jarvis
house map the film's location has been
recreated to perfection but with so much
water around the locale this map will
require strong coordination from the
survivors and the Jason that moves
quickly around in water could be the
best pick for this map the internal deck
of this house looks magnificent and
probably the most detailed to date right
I can't wait any longer let's talk about
Chuck introducing the first counselor to
be added to the Friday the 13th ranks
Mitch
Floyd I'm sure any movie fan will pick
up on his similarities to Chuck from
Friday the 13th part 3 in the first
screenshot we were given his appearance
is now on the exact same with the hoop
shirt the glasses the beard and even the
bandana
he even has a lovely tie-dyed shirt to
push the hippie vibes let's hope he
survives longer than his movie
counterpart Chuck
I mean mitch has some interesting stats
to consider his 9 out of 10 for
composure means he's not one to be
scared of Jason and he's 8 out of 10
repair skills will make those mechanic
mini games a doddle his stealth stat at
6 out of 10 is above average so he looks
like he's a real option sadly he's other
stats are low and only 2 out of 10 for
look so those moments of complete fluke
such as not being hurt by climbing
through a broken window or somehow
having reduced damage from a machete to
the head they're not possible with Mitch
they deserve to die
make them suffer mr. Floyd will not be
so lucky so don't expect a miracle and
you'll be fine
similarly Mitch won't be outrunning
Jason as his stamina makes me look like
I'm in tip-top shape and his strength is
pretty much non-existent too if you want
to play as Mitch Floyd stick with the
group and hope your composure will make
Jason miss you cowering in a corner
Mitch Floyd will be completely free and
releases you've guessed it on Friday the
13th finally a new multi pack is here
which will not be free but could be
tempting ten brand spanking new remotes
will be lightening up Crystal Lake the
funny dance
brushing shoulder the superhero pose the
good old Flo boogie a little bit of a
wave this crazy sheet a bit of crying
thinking about things someone who feels
a bit on edge and some more dancing I've
got to admit I really like the funny
dance but am I willing to hand over $2
for the privilege
Who am I kidding year I'm gonna bloody
buy it
[Music]
so then we have five new things coming
to Friday the 13th on Friday the 13th
what do you think - the latest offerings
and will you be trying out Mitch I'd
love to know your thoughts I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]